on ne bouge pas pendant le djing d'être
battisti qu'est ce que c'est
interview nul vous êtes prêts oui
thierry est ce que vous préférez votre
père ou votre mère je préfère noël
mamère ouais
est ce que vous ferez hitler ou staline
à staline ah ouais haoues qu'il a tué
plus de gens vachement plus 40 millions
en plus d'entre eux pensent que le mec
est plus fort et plus travaillent cas
alors vous partez trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial
trois ans c'est long à déjà j'y vais pas
c'est long trois ans vous avez le choix
entre trois personnes
thomas valentin le directeur des
programmes de m6 dominique farrugia
le directeur des programmes de canal +
où etienne mougeotte enfin j'aurais fait
je réfléchis même pas à etienne
mougeotte
ah ouais on doit bien se marier avec lui
est ce que vous pourriez faire l'amour
avec une fille très laide ou avec très
beau mais en général je préfère tout
simplement faire l'amour avec avec ceux
ou celles qui veulent quoi d'accord oui
sans que soient obligés des forces parce
que moi j'aime pas ta paix et à brigitte
chaud
bien qu est-ce qui fait peur tout seul à
chaque possession
j'espère julien lepers tulle est ce que
je vais faire horrifié réincarné en
bataille ou en fontaine attention un
indice ne s'affiche pas sur notre écran
a ni l'homme ni l'un ni l'autre à vos
bonnes réponses
c'est évidemment la bonne réponse ramène
applaudissez ba tan vous rendez compte
que vous applaudissez n'importe quelle
scène publique de télévision
alors vous allez me faire laplaud
drucker on l'a répété matelots drucker
c'est comme ça va me faire la peau du
temps
les randonneurs mois et voilà
bienvenue à champs elysées patrick
bonnel ya c'est bien pour la fabriquer
ils ont fait des progrès en à plaudren
alors un ami débarque chez vous à
l'improviste
oui je n'ai pas d'amis ce qui vous gêne
le plus qu'ils trouvent sur votre table
de nuit
mein kampf oui l'effroyable imposture de
thierry meyssan ou un godemiché alors
france sans hésiter thierry meyssan
parce que je dois vous dire que je les
regardais dans votre émission à thierry
et j'ai fait au [ __ ] mais donc mais
tout les qu'une immense supercherie et
ça se trouve super u en sécurité et
après je l' ai vu dans d'autres
émissions de télé se faire démonter la
gueule et je me suis aperçu donc que cet
homme qui avait l'air ma foi assez
gentil était peut-être un petit peu
farfelue donc tu adores la science
fiction donc thierry meyssan même
réponse bien dans la grange voire de
capotage si vous aviez un perroquet oui
voulu apprendriez ta ferme et le gaz
tout ce que vous dites ça parce que je
suis d'origine juive plus yeux c'est pas
bien alors applaudissements à la maurice
herzog
fermez le gall ta pensée la capote une
coco arrête là coco je vais dire je vais
dire t'as pensé atteindre le gaz parce
que chez moi c'est les plaques
électriques tellement fou voilà alors
vous préféreriez mourir comme otis
redding dans un crash d'avion
john lennon tué à bout portant claude
françois dans une baignoire avec un jeu
tu je sais pas quoi john bonham le
batteur de led zep étouffé dans son vomi
ou janis joplin par overdose
voilà quel programme art est une star
fois prendre à mourir comme une star
mais qu'at elle
je préfèrerais mourir comme comme comme
patrick roy a annon parle pas assez
d'eux patrick rondat je trouve ça bien
dommage non comme philippe de
dieuleveult dans l'incertitude la plus
totale
c'est gai cette émission à il est mort
qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est m il est mort
vive
ici c'est super j'ai adoré michaël youn
oeuvre non je vais rester
est-ce que vous préféreriez avoir un nez
supplémentaires un oeil supplémentaires
a indiqué quoi un sexe supplémentaires
pourquoi pourquoi pas ce que je vais
vous dire la vérité
bas les masques ce soir le jour de la
distribution des beats way
malheureusement dans la file d'attenté
gt gt à la fin et donc j'ai eu un j'en
ai eu une vraie merde